over the game from the Olympia so white
is this the match Norway versus us that
played today and this is the the fourth
port and we have the Grandmaster from
North Norway Oh
get down 25:37 yeah his name is first
his wife yes and that's the game by Sam
Shanklin he played really well this game
and won and this was the first win for
the US team very nice game by Sam so II
foresee five guys let's take a look at
this opening first question comes to you
what's the name of this opening many
hands excellent you Sicilian defense
excellent choice
even though same was playing black he
choose to play and a good opening
aggressive opening and to go for the win
instead of trying to just make a draw
with black and this was a great opening
choice might have 3d6
united six eight six
what's the name of this system we know
the opening is called Sicilian defense
but then what's the name of this system
here that he just played because if you
play g6 that's a different system right
what system is this r2 this one
juggler and this one is the one that
simply this nigh Dorf okay it's very
sharp line okay this guy goes Bishop g5
9 37228 6 g 6 interesting he just wants
to go Bishop to g7 to do the fianchetto
and I don't know how much the theory and
this is but doesn't look like a big
theoretical idea but now actually when
he plays dis g6
besides Bishop g7 here now he 5 tells us
his plan is actually to prevent a knight
from coming to f5 that's what he's
trying to do okay so he is attacking the
knight 93 Bishop e7 so it just keeps the
bishop on e7 because obviously if you
make them move e5 you're not gonna go
Bishop g7 because then d6 pawn shop so
he goes Bishop yourself King p1 b5 in
this opening it's a prophylactic move it
so it's a useful move you put the King
to a safer Square not an open top of the
file so now b5 in this opening it's not
so important to Castle right away it's
more important to play this moves Bishop
e7 Luke see it and that's what he is
doing here okay
80 Queen c7 first King f8 he wants to
put the King on g7 perhaps that's why he
played them of King f8 he didn't want to
cancer because this pawns a little bit
loose so he thought maybe keep the roof
on h8 is fine and work it out okay doll
is trying to be aggressive I mean here
the white pieces and yeah he's trying to
also you know do something here on the
Kings side but shrunken goes Knight b6
now trying to go 94th okay take on a
three and try to put pressure
g3 Brooke p8 Europe rook is very useful
on this V file here you'll see later on
Bishop d6 very big decision very big
decision to give up the bishop here but
I believe he felt already and some sort
of danger here that's before even Knight
a for ideas I mean there's a lot of
pressure here so that's why he took
English pastry hey it looks like simple
just exchanging kind of idea but the
problem for him is the bad news is his
King is going to be under tremendous
attack ish a5 Frankland is very
seriously trying to attack now Group C
now be for a for the above needs to be
considered 95 orchid Ellis trying to
exchange position the rook takes d5 but
the problem for him is he is one move
too slow here if you could have a pawn
on c3 is you can try to restrain the
advance of the white pawns because that
way a3 he can just go back and there's
no before break but now he is just late
a for hitting the knight Knight is under
attack you cannot do that and now
Charlotte breaks through with d4 now the
lines are gonna go open and whose pieces
are gonna be active on those lines
lots pieces yeah III start watching this
game around 8 a.m. this morning and no
no no no Alex I was watching it online
the games so you watch online just 24
calm chest-bump website so it's like you
can watch against online so here you
played 93 in here who is gonna find a
neat move here by Graham master shunt
want to get the first win for the USA
team
yes
pay attention pay attention what is the
guy trying to do pay very close
attention yeah he wants to take your
queen you need a strong move you know
you need it now I'm just animal you need
a strong move here to do this yes what's
the move today close very close very
close but unfortunately not that little
bit fancier yes yes and he is getting it
Bravo
we see three look at that move now the
point is what is black threatening now
are to a three yes a three rugby -
threat and it be three than just a two
takes rook a a check and mate so let's
say you go here because you're
threatening mate repeat two ideas check
check animate okay
okay so Italy is very strong so now and
he goes here king c1 trying to UM pin
the pin in all this I mean he cannot
really defend this position I mean his
position is really really bad here and
Bishop is not in a game yet yeah Bishop
was in it will be completely lost
immediately but now what's the move here
the Queen is under attack so what do you
do now
he
takes a queen
king d2 and it stops it you don't want
to give up your queen in order to try to
quit so something better here now I just
played here actually Quincy for the next
zone move now trying to get in here
White King is completely weak here with
no defenses around it okay and now if he
tries to repeat and go Sears now which
guy's gonna get involved the a guy is
gonna get involved now threat is Luke
takes me to check Knight cannot take it
it's hanging
so he goes b3 queen c3 with the powerful
threat off push if he moves away Queen
may check
checkmate it's always nice when you but
to two hours into the round you're
playing black and your team is already
leading by one so it was there wasn't
that the result of the match was never
in doubt you know Carlsen didn't get
anything he was in fact slightly worse
against marijuana but Corona just repeat
it at the end because it was good enough
Wesley was also slightly better at the
whole game maybe much put in some point
but didn't take too much risk he caught
one another excellent game and this was
the shotgun game so so yeah he's
opponent I don't know what he did he
played rock h2 I really don't understand
this move that just not doing anything
basically so what's the move why did we
go Kings Queen support to play what not
only our turn
a treif 1083 takes first because there's
no bitter in our to root xp3 okay so he
takes and now Michael now you can do now
no defense in this position now the
threat is let it check and pick up the
phone and see to it I mean black pieces
are all over the place
- Roxanna Quinn really really dominating
position King b1 he's trying to escape
are you gonna let him do that of course
not check now he goes here
we need to take the pawn back and
threatened threatened our mate on c1 so
the only way product protect his Queen
d2 and now now it's time to pick up some
material right you see it yeah go thank
you very much for the pawn chick he
blocks it up yes absolutely and this was
the last game of the game because it
looks really really painful p1c watch
this for why because he's down 2 pounds
and he's under tremendous attack and no
contra play and the next move is to win
the third pawn and Bishop is gonna join
into action Bishop one g5 is gonna be
really deadly because it's gonna just
simply you know attack the Queen and so
a very convincing victory for shaman
yeah his opponent just resigned here
because he just really bad so very very
convincing victory and you know at the
moment as I mentioned at the moment
we're tied for first with Ukraine with
16 points we're in first place we're
tied in Ukraine we defeated Ukraine
actually in our our own match but there
is Russia a point behind so it's still
you know right I mean but so it's very
important u.s. wins their remaining two
matches I don't think anything will have
a still a better tie break even if
Ukraine win so I think we still doing
great but the most important thing is
just not to make sure no slips no
accidents against teams that we're
supposed to be tomorrow Georgia and we
have played already all the top teams so
the final round will have probably a
strong team again but will be favorite
against any of them so this is the big
game okay with block winning in a team
events like this it's very very
important
let's see now if you remember this game
from beginning till the end 31 moles all
right let's see the over review now go
which opening we have right now Sicilian
defense and which line of the seats
India Shanklin is playing yes night off
all right
now he's trying to take and double up
tonight yeah night bt7 you're now
letting that happen question it g6 yeah
it looks like he wants to go Bishop g7
that's actually where I thought in the
beginning also but actually but actually
you want to play e5 mainly that's his
main idea okay
okay focus on this don't worry about
that yeah now what's the move why did he
play g6 remember how do yes continue yo
you should be seven and now what is the
typical idea here for black to do
typical idea for night off so what's the
move here yes
be 5v5 we should be seven right got a
plea active now yes means she said it
first
now King f8 now so you didn't want to
put a bishop there or be sure because
it's kind of not doing anything against
the e4 pawn so he wants to equal might
be six rook b8 right that's kind of a
good idea you know it's yes h4 orchid a
was trying to attack now yes excellent
going to see for potentially preparing
it preparing it to have power it not to
play before and with the power takes how
are we gonna capture back remember quick
so you have before break okay you want
to have the Queen for the before break
now
don't take him let him take you okay so
what do you do you go for attack see
this is you could see the terror that
that the white is already did something
wrong here I think taking was a mistake
also
inviting the roof to come in you know
that also wasn't the best I think he's
already in trouble here by doing this
it's just very dangerous
I think this player perhaps miss this a
four on before idea would curtail
because iron I maybe was thinking just
be for a for and he thought okay I'm
doing alright
but obviously is gonna play this a
formal was back it now you want to open
up the be file right to be able to do
you got it
threatening checkmate orbiter and now
need move here's who is remembering the
need move by Grandmaster everybody
raising their hands very good you
excellent job
very strong yes threatening a tree now
he goes here and now Michael perfect
rook a to and now what's the idea
remember you a three yes because he
cannot push Petrie because Luke takes me
three really it seems like so effortless
you know like I mean the white is 2540
is a strong G I mean solid GM but yeah
just play badly because just same one
very easily this one which is great yes
coming in and now finishing touch now
finishing touch needs to be precise you
check out yeah if it comes up here you
take on c2 with the rook and then pick
up the Queen you go Siri now
yes
threating this the only way to stop it
you don't have Queenie trick we take the
tree and now simply let's also get
couple of pounds not only your winning
pounds to gain material you also want to
get your bishop in because when Bishop
comes in then he certainly cannot defend
this position so what is the idea
correct and now don't stop it there
don't stop it there continue yes and he
resigned I mean he's gonna lose another
pawn but if this part moves you know
you're not interested in winning pawns
here what are you interested in here
we're diggin g5 and that is the game
over right there
complete domination and two again
we just have to wait for two more rounds
two more rounds it's a very close
Olympia I mean the the top three teams
it's pretty clear right now that the
fight fight for this first three place
is gonna be involving the Ukraine u.s. I
mean at this point you know if US
doesn't win gold it's gonna be big
disappointment because they've played
all the best teams they defeated almost
all the best teams they were beating
Russia we're unfortunate to draw but at
the moment I think u.s. is looking very
good
so yeah but Russia and Ukraine they're
gonna be fighting very hard as well
because they still have chances there
are a couple of other teams out there
that are close like two points away like
Czech Republic Georgia but I think you
know it's not it gonna be easy
you know they don't need to win all
right
okay guys excellent we have about 20
more minutes left so we're gonna do some
practice games now okay let's let pair
you up with some players so